all right
hi everyone this we are looking at some
design questions
to do with arrays for wolfram language
and this is a continuation of some
meetings that we had
a few months ago working towards
uh streamlining how one deals with the
rise
so where is the whole inserting is this
is this here
is this the insertion story right i
would i would include it in the second
part of this where i say
alternative default rules for thread but
because we don't have tally today i
wasn't planning to discuss that
particular
but wait a second wait a second but but
we had already made this design of this
insertion thing right
what happened we had some ideas we
didn't have a design
exactly well we had a large part of the
design i think that's something we need
to finish
and that's something that etienne is
also involved with is that in here or
not
i tried calling him but i haven't gotten
a hold of him yet
okay i think we basically should go back
to what i had already
worked on written down before so we have
an august 31st one
so this was
okay so this is this insertion idea
right
and where is the most recent version of
the insertion idea
there's a notebook called array reduce
um and sometimes
ray reduces something that was in 12 2
right and
yeah and and then there's an array
operations 03.
i already looked at that so i just
pulled up right so that's something that
uh the end road but there's no insertion
there
where is this
no i i think that's the uh what you had
in the other notebook is the
last thing we discussed about arranged
session
okay but the concept was that
that you know the basic concept was
that um you have
uh
you say you know the the the key issue
is you've got something like this and
you want to
and our default is to add
a b like this right
right so we want the possibility of
adding it in a different way
right that's the key key issue
and that's something that applies to
lots of operations
right yep and
what we had imagined was this thing we
called
insertion right where we say
um just like we now have splice
we would say plus insertion of this
or something like that and that would
mean
that that is a i don't know whether
that's the right word but that is a
um you know that's being done
um at a deeper level
right right now
is this a well-defined concept
i mean i think it is basically a um you
know this can be implemented
yeah i don't think so and and it's not
easy to implement no
okay well okay well very hard to
implement
okay great then then it adds value
the then okay so
but the main problem we're trying to
solve here is
the endless use of you know hash plus a
b
right mapping that over
the the list right we're trying to make
that
simpler am i making sense by the way
shouldn't insertion also take like a
level spec or something yes it should
take a level spectrum
at some other level exactly
right i mean so so the concept
would be you know thing
and some kind of level so really though
this is
i mean it seems like in general this
operation
is is going to be equivalent to that map
i would think so with a different
function of course
right i would think so so i mean just to
be i would not be completely surprised
if there wasn't some identity
between it and something to do with
splice maybe i'm wrong
no splice is
right what's up here this place is
i'm aware it disappears but i mean what
is there not
okay so one way to think about this
insertion thing
is that it is
i guess it's just a map i guess it's
just doing the map
um
pretty sure it's just that
yes perhaps the question is which
operations
just suspected they're irrelevant
why does this thing not deal with copy
okay never mind um
okay there we go what's that say that
again yes i was wondering which
operations
uh are expected to
well let's imagine the case let's just
imagine
if f if an arbitrary f so i mean this
might not work
but let's just think about that for a
second um
you know if it was the case that f of
i mean so this is kind of like local
some kind of local listability
local threading or you know
another possible word for it would be
threaded
but in that sense it's very similar to
discussion of of a splice
in that splice only reacts to lists well
except
we need to change that we need a version
of splice we've talked about this before
that can operate in a given head
right but yeah does spice work with up
values
i assume yes okay
but so could splice work if if you gave
splice a
second argument that was a head could it
splice into that head
and you could certainly write something
like that in the top level but it
probably wouldn't be very efficient
so i imagine it's possible
okay so so this
imagine i think threaded is a better
name than insertion by the way
i agree
so what would happen okay so this is
f list comma threaded
blah blah blah a b now
threaded would be equivalent to
calling thread on
um uh
okay if i say thread f of
you know a b
right now that will give this
so what is this thing equivalent to
threaded am i being confused is this not
an equivalent
kind of like map thread
which is like maps
right so with the two by two um array
and the a b is equivalent to map thread
of plus
comma and then those two those two lists
this thing hit no wait a minute this
this you know the thing you had above
the thing above that's below percent
223.
okay yeah that that's a map thread
i think we might get ourselves into
trouble thinking about this in terms of
thread because
the illicitable threading uses multiple
levels of thread
what do you mean it's not just a single
thread
it basically has to be repeated
you mean less stability repeats right
the stability
well let's not give up on the concept of
thinking about the thread because map
thread
doesn't repeat
right but isn't that why you want the
level
the level would be yes like subtracting
one
every time until you reach zero reach
zero
well yes i mean we might want to an at a
level and through certain levels
oh i see i see well i mean
go ahead through certain levels
so again what meaning would it have to
do it at multiple levels
i'm not sure because i mean rob was
bringing up the idea that
listability does things at multiple
levels
but i really like the name threaded by
the way i think that's actually an easy
to understand
thing you know it's a threaded
you're adding it in a threaded way
you know so
okay so let's look at this again
what could be can this work
so what does this exactly mean this
means okay so you're saying basically
uh where did i have that is it what is
this
what what is this equivalent to
if i say okay so first of all if this
isn't a list
right well i mean the problem is you we
don't know what that's equivalent to
because
it depends on list right so threaded
threaded needs to somehow reach outside
which is why i
think i'm very skeptical of this
approach
right the threaded needs to know what
the other arguments to a function
it's inside of in order to know how so
does the stability
no it doesn't so let's try what he works
from the top down
and there's only one i see what you're
saying okay
okay go ahead jose yeah let's try what
christopher was suggesting so
that thing you just wrote could be map
thread of
f and then the list of the various
arguments
list one a b is two
and then if if this happens to be valid
the prediction can be done if not okay
so let me understand what that means
because what i would expect this to do
is if this was x y
one two
um
yeah put another length to list there
with it with another well let's let's
just do here
you're saying of depth to list here
links to
length two that's anything you want
i'm confused now so
okay so this that's a length one thing
that's the length one yes
oh length two okay uv
okay let me understand what this just
did
what that's like this ability you want
you want that you want to repeat the a b
i want the a b to go all the way down
right so it needs to be repeated
in a list of length two
to do to do thinking of right
um
right so but the whole point is what
we're trying to do
and i see etienne has joined also hi
yes sorry what we're trying to do here
is understand so we're talking about
your insertion
or whatever it's called we prefer the
name threaded right now
and um i mean the the overall goal
just to be clear is this thing here okay
so actually sandra is asking what would
this actually produce
okay so this would produce um this would
be uh
let's see five let's see what is this
going to produce this one
c three plus a four plus b
right so it is threading down to the
lowest level there
and if it was if it was told a level
so this would be um
it would be here threaded down to a
certain
at a thread at a certain level
and this would be so for example this
would be the level one thing
in which case it would be the you know
this would say
threaded at a certain level
i think that a good way to think about
level specifications here
is thinking about how you promote
the dimension list of the right term
because in the end you have it right
a comma b has to become a two by two
thing and now it's a two thing
so where do you add the extra two do you
have it at the beginning of the
dimensional list or at the end
or in between if you have a more complex
object
i think that's better right so what
you're saying is what operation do we
have right now
that does that kind of replication of a
tensor
i think maybe it was array pad or
something like that
with a complex syntax
i also implemented numeric utilities
a symbol i forgot the name maybe array
replicate
uh which is something we decided uh
okay a few months ago that we should do
it just to play with it at least
that's about constant array what's it
called constant array
right constant array is the way to
replicate an array
i see oh yeah yeah constant array yeah
and and the
the thing that i did let me find it's uh
it's name wait a minute sanders pointing
out that in our live stream that he's
already implemented a function called
generalized map thread
in the function repository
that will be cool okay let's see what it
does
it solves a different problem
what is it doing it's
it my recollection of it is that it
allows scalars
and sort of ragged things
well that's interesting too right we
talked about it
um okay so that's a different that's yet
a different thing
yes check numerical utilities backtick
array replicate sorry what was it called
numerical what
numeric array utilities
backtick array replicate
you'll not have to load numerical
utilities here i have to do
i don't know i get
and this is a string or not yeah not
yeah you can check your information
about that like question mark
and should
what the heck oh my god that was really
funky
that was a how do i oh wow that's
exciting i do backspace and it
it on pythons it
that's bad see those spaces there that's
a that's probably a bug in the handling
of um information handling do you know
what i'm saying
yeah i don't know somebody report that
please yep i got it the
the yeah they're and also the way it
says symbol at the top is also wrong
i mean this is not a top-level thing
yeah this is just uh oh i know i'm well
aware
i'm aware of that it's just a thing
where
the question mark is is not being as
smart as it could be
okay and
this i think is a design we decided
quite some time ago
uh yeah you can
specify the level that gets replicated
and how many times gets replicated
and uh
[Music]
and what did we do with this go ahead
yeah actually
yeah the first two lines is the same is
the same thing just explain in a
different way
actually each line is doubled just
explained in a different way
right
well so hold on so
this is a function that we believe is
independent of all other functions
this this array replicate yeah we could
yeah yeah we could make it a top level
um also the idea was to
you know implemented to play with it and
and
well it should certainly be a function
repository if nothing else
it should be in the function repository
now okay look let's okay
okay so first point is we need to make
forward progress on this threaded idea
and what is the relationship oh boy this
is yet a different thing this level
applied
thing isn't that like array reduce um
yes look at the second uh
uh subsection heading okay so this we
believe this
that level applied became array reduced
is that true uh
i think they are no no no headdress
version versus explicit form
i mean i'm not convinced uh
that the tedras form
is super useful but yes
well it's like a column wise addition
how do you do column wise edition what's
the right way to think about column wise
addition
is it level applied of plus comma or
total comma
two or what yeah
i would say total comma at least two
probably
okay so so this is another thing so this
is another topic here this is the
headdress form
of array reduce
okay otherwise known as level applied
okay sandra makes a comment here
okay hold on sandra is saying adding or
subtracting a constant vector from a
large set of vectors is something i
commonly do
yes i agree with you i agree with you
that's a very common thing to want to do
i mean this is the most common thing is
you're doing this
and um you know that second thing could
be a constant array or whatever but
but the main point is you want it to
burrow
inside and just do that without having
to do this
right we've picked a default which
is you know listify at the thread at the
top level
sometimes you want it to listify at the
at the lowest level
instead and that's what we're trying to
solve with this
so look let's jose maybe maybe you can
uh pursue this issue of whether threaded
can be made to work whether this is
makes sense i mean i think what's going
to happen here is let's say that the
lists are of incompatible shapes and
sizes and so on
well just like the stability it's going
to fail
right and that's okay you know
incompatible shapes
just like the stability would say that
that makes sense
what i don't know how to do here is that
if we have an array of
of depth three how do you specify
whether you want
this at level two or it's always you
give a second argument
threaded so in other words here
what this would do is it would say you
know comma two or something
would say do this threading at level two
in each of these lists
which means which is equivalent to that
threaded thing
i suspect okay so listen uh well
i mean if right if you have one other
list that's well defined i'm not
convinced that's well defined
if it isn't deep enough but but listen
threaded a b
comma constantly specified level is
equivalent
to simply taking to simply constructing
that threaded thing as equivalent to
constructing
an appropriate replicated tensor and
then just using the stability
if i'm not mistaken i think it's
equivalent to map
i mean that example we had above uh the
example i sent it before was kind of a
typo written thing but i mean just it's
just mapping it
level whatever fair enough
but but well i'm not sure i i still
i still think map thread and the number
two you wrote there could be the second
or the third argument of map thread
it says that we need replication yeah
right once it's replicated
and and maybe there needs to be a way
this is kind of replication based on
environment
how much replication depends on how deep
the the ambient lists are
there's not going to be a way of getting
around i mean the basic point is there
are two different defaults that are
useful
for you know adding a vector to a list
of vectors
right and we picked one and you could
pick the other and we need a way to
specify the other and that's really all
this comes down to
am i making sense and you know we could
imagine as we've discussed
in some of these places here that
um you know
in an extreme case if we think plus is
the main thing
you know we could imagine i mean i don't
think we have a lot of syntax available
to do this i mean you know
there is presumably syntax like maybe no
slash plus doesn't work
that's already taken syntax i mean slash
minus but but you know all of these
things it doesn't really make a lot of
sense we'd have to
i mean i suppose what we could do
for code elegance we could imagine
something
where we have a you know a special
character i don't know what it would be
let's let's say
a bullet or something that means
um the threaded version
it's just a little general because again
you would like to have other levels
absolutely so we need this threaded
thing but this is
this just means means the threaded
version at the lowest level
well do you mean the lowest level or the
lowest matching level
oh interesting question
for that in part setting so if you set a
part
it goes to the first level that tries to
go to the first level that matches the
dimension
of the setting
and that's top down but we might want to
think about this as bottom up
with with a matching type thing right
okay look i this is something go ahead
let me point out that none of this
can work without changing the evaluator
okay
well because otherwise the list plus is
listable and so then it won't
nothing will work right yeah
well this has to be this just has to be
a
a thing that goes ahead of structure
which
yes is a part of the evaluator but but
but we already did that for the
the packed array stuff has to be done
before before it hits structure
so i think this example here works if f
is not listable
um or i haven't tested it much but i
think it works if f is not listable but
of course most of the examples we care
about is where f is listable
well okay so this so let's say we say
um i've got my example here
okay so now i say threaded here
oh i think it is this is only a two
argument thing
so i i don't think this okay okay fine
okay
right so correct behavior
is it hold on
yes that's the correct behavior if you
do a slash start f goes to plus you'll
get
the uh after yeah and after the fact
yeah that's exactly what we want
that's exactly what we want all right
look the objective is we've got to get
to this
place and you know we've got at least a
somewhat reasonable idea here so let's
study it some more
and let's now come back to the main part
of the agenda
which i hijacked here before we leave
this
what could be a function that does this
from outside so it takes
the array you have in the first argument
then the a b
and it specifies a level at what you
want to do
so i have the same argument structure as
map thread
right something similar perhaps you you
can specify
independent levels for individual arrays
which you want to do
so what are you saying that this is for
what so i'm trying to do this
the explicit version the explicit
version of this exactly
okay so this is okay this is an implicit
implicit headdress version threading
and now we want headdress
no no i'm calling what you just did the
headdress version
it's not a headdress a headdress would
be would be modifying the f
oh okay exactly okay
explicit version so so going back to
sanders examples if
we have an array and a vector and we
want to displace the array by the vector
we could have a function that takes the
array and the vector
i see so what you're saying is you're
saying something like
um you know map within or something
um
the original array and the
and the i mean the big array let's see
is there some way of generalizing it to
i mean maybe this will make the
arguments too complicated but maybe it
would also be possible to generalize it
to arbitrary numbers of arrays
sure yeah right so this would be
that's not clear how the argument then
it would have to be more like map thread
where these two things are in a list
right but i mean the question is is is
there some
way of specifying those that isn't
overly complicated and where
i mean like for example you normally
need to specify different levels for
each of the different arrays
and there's complicated questions about
like the ordering
and stuff like that once you have three
so i i'm not sure it can really work
without
right well i mean so so well okay one
possibility right you crazy syntax with
with level arrows here
i'm just saying even with that though
there might be ambiguity about the order
in which to apply these
things yeah i get it but but i think the
obvious thing if you applied in one of
these functions without folding
then it applies simultaneously it's f of
multi-arguments i guess my point is that
whatever is a problem here will be also
a problem in the
in the threaded case right because this
is trying to do the same
probably this is even more powerful
exactly
yes i agree but i mean the threaded case
the default case of low level
you know it goes to the lowest level
and it just adds in the vector and so on
that's the default case that we want
so all other cases are bonus
but important and here
is go ahead same thing this could do the
same thing by default
it realizes you have a vector on the
third argument
and then a matrix and it tries to push
the vector to the
deepest right right
actually related to that though there's
the question of how it knows
so if the arguments of f if f needed to
be uh
let's say the argument order f was
reversed right then you can't just have
it so it takes quotes you know
the big matrix first and the little
vector second
absolutely i see so how does it know
right how does it know that that this
well okay how does it know that it
should push what is the semantics of it
pushing
because when you have a threaded thing
you are you are breaking the symmetry
see what i'm saying we can make this to
thread through the
deepest level of everything
i see
i mean deep as compatible or deepest
deepest
i i would say deepest the best and if it
wasn't market complain
i i would say it they have to coincide
because it would return it would have uh
f of it would be list of lists of f
of a b comma x comma f of a b comma y
etc
right no i would say no if a b
is a vector then it will return a list
of
f of a b x y and f of a b one two
i i would argue that's deepest
compatible because deepest deepest would
be you just apply
you know i would have thought it would
be this
no but this isn't right this isn't right
this way around isn't right
i think this is not a symmetrical thing
well i mean
what you just wrote i think doesn't make
sense though because you're breaking up
the a b
yeah yeah but then how do you do there i
mean i understand what what good is this
if it doesn't actually do the equivalent
of the threaded thing
at the lowest level for the plus case
namely this
all right let's go back to our main part
of discussion and let's come back to
this maybe next week
um but i mean we need to keep pushing on
this because
as i say the one thing we know we
absolutely need
is this behavior here right
so generalizing that and understanding
how to do that in the best possible way
is a fine thing but that's behavior we
know we need
makes sense yes yes i
i agree with that it's just that that
language
will probably hide something that we see
better with the explicit version but we
will explore well i understand i
understand
okay let's come to your actual agenda
okay so
let me just okay so this part had
two parts one is some sort of
enumeration of
various problems that we have discussed
at
points but in in the in the first area
the most important thing i wanted to
mention
was uh now this you can close this this
first point
let's go to transposition first
so first we want to implement this this
is not yet implemented but
really i thought that was implemented i
thought we had the two-way rule
wait a minute the two-way rule thing
what's that we plan to implement it but
it's not implemented yet
okay so so i but we will i think i'm
more convinced now after
going through the various things i'm
more convinced that this notation is is
useful
wait there is a version like there's a
usage in the documentation that has the
two-way rule thing maybe it's a
different
maybe it's different it's a one-way rule
right that we're discussing
it's a one-way rule yes oh okay the
two-way rule exists
oh i see okay right the the the
i thought it existed okay now what does
the one-way rule mean because that i
don't understand so well
exactly you can evaluate this code on
the left
and we test it so now the most important
case of this
is the um
[Music]
the case in which we map to the deepest
level so
try an array try what would you like me
to try
try and transpose with an array any
array of
depth three or something
try dimensions two three four it's
always oh i see okay clear there when
when dimensions are different
okay right now
what do you want me to do you want me to
say transpose this
right now transpose one goes to three
for example
and check the dimensions of that
so we've cyclically permuted our
it happens to be cyclic in this case
exactly if you had a five
if you started with two three four five
the five would be left
that's basically pushing the two in the
third position
in the dimension list yeah inserting i
think that would be the best way to
describe it
right so if i go here it's not really
inserting because it's removing also two
so it's moving the two
it's uh yeah we're moving it and then
yeah yeah okay fine three hold on a
second one two three
means yes okay so it's taking
what was level one and it is making it
level three yeah right
yeah that seems useful because basically
go ahead is it cyclically permuting
everything in between
exactly so so if you had like
a two goes well i guess we need one more
level
so add a six and you do like a two goes
to four
it looks like it's equivalent to calling
delete and then calling insert
which is probably the right thing yep
right hold on so 2 goes to 4
right so levels 1 and 5 were unchanged
and then
two three and four were sort of
cyclically permuted
right i mean three four levels two three
and four which are
three four five became four five three
that's why the rule is needed because
this is not equivalent to four goes to
two
while the two-way rule is symmetric in
that sense
it's it's just an exchange
so when would we use this i found this
very useful
when i when i developed uh a reduce for
example
uh i would i would use it everywhere
yeah yes even to describe so there was a
notebook a long time ago
i think it's called array operation
reduce etc
and uh and it was to it was for me to
understand
reduce and level apply and even map
thread and map
and uh by using this transpose
it was very easy to to code everything
and everything was clear
so basically the basic point of this
kind of transposition
is meet me on a certain level in some
sense
you've got an operation it has to
correspond some level has to correspond
is that right i mean is that the way to
think about this yes
i think so and for example one case
which is extremely useful and we used a
lot
internally is when we you are sending
the first level to the
to the deepest level or vice versa
does that go say two error minus one or
does that not supported
uh well i have a question further down
saying whether we want
to support that it's a bit weird to have
a minus one inside transpose
so perhaps we need a different notation
but that particular case
is i have internal functions called
array of lists
a list of arrays imagine that you have a
three matrix
of coordinates x y c sometimes you want
a list of three with the array of of
all x's the array of of all wise and the
rays of all
seas
why isn't that transpose it is a
transpose but it's
it's a transpose that people have to
work on the permutation for some time
okay but so that's sort of what the
flatten
does to some extent too
that alternate argument for flatten
correct because flatten incorporates
transpose right
yeah so are you proposing some kind of
new functions that are special
special cases of this
well i i'm asking whether minus one
is acceptable i mean it doesn't look too
weird to have two
one goes to minus one and minus one goes
to one i don't think so
no that would be that would be great
because that's i mean that's i have
i have functions i've had to write
called transpose first to last and
transpose last to first
because it's so hard to figure out the
permutation exactly
exactly rob you have a very strange
background noise
oh sorry that was my chair creaking no
no but no matter
the um
but do we think that there's a useful
named function that represents some of
these kinds of things
i mean rob said he had one that um
uh yeah okay
well all right
so i i mean to me it seems anybody
objecting to this arrow notation
this rule notation seems good to me
i think it's good okay yeah
and i think the minus one is fine too
okay good so i do have one question
though what happens if you want to do
multiple if you want to i mean
is it well defined to do no i think you
just have to do multiple transpose
operations
i'm just saying if you want these levels
like for example let's say you want some
kind of block matrix that is
where you say levels
okay so imagine you needed something you
could do one after the other but then
it's probably just much more clear if
you just write multiple transposes
well no it's actually i think you could
do one after the other and i think you
could actually implement it by
by figuring out the permutation for each
one
and then then permuting the permutation
according to the
to the dimensions what about something
like this does that make any sense
i'm not even sure how to try to
understand that
well so what i'm imagining is let's
imagine you have a block matrix
okay so you've got maybe i'm confused
you've got a well a matrix of matrices
okay and you want to take
the let's say more to the point you
might have levels three
four
goes to levels one two i suppose that's
a
is that does that make any sense
well it would be a matter of finding the
corresponding
permutation now the general case of this
might be complicated because this is not
just a product of two permutations
that might not permute a commute i
understand that is this well defined
what this should mean
well in this case which is simple i
think yes but if
you have an array of level of depth
seven and there is nothing consecutive
you don't know what to do with
intermediate levels
so in other words if you say if these
two levels are disjoint
if this was one three goes to three
seven
i have no idea what to do with levels
two and four etc
it's not so simple as just cyclic as
before
yeah i think it might be better as a
sequence of
your one-way rules and then you can
always figure out the permutation
yeah but maybe that's not conceptually
how you want to think about it
yeah i i see what you're thinking about
i'm i'm not clear as to whether it's
always well defined
but more than well-defined it's a matter
of finding an arbitrary choice of what
to do with the other
levels yeah sandra is also commenting
what if the second thing is degenerate
that's totally weird
well okay i think this is not making it
this
i
i mean you can always fold in if you
really want to do multiple of these
transpose i guess you can always fold
them in or we can provide a syntax we
can have a list of these rules
[Music]
yeah it could could have a flattened
thing like one and three goes to seven
it's flattened and then put at seven i
don't know well right i don't know if
that's a good idea either
you know i think it might be better to
keep that behavior in flattened
honestly yeah because
these guys think of them as permutations
you can certainly handle a list of rules
easily if you don't if they're no longer
permutations then it's really
problematic
right okay
nick is asking about what if you move a
level to level zero could it do
something with the head
no no that's not the right totally weird
[Music]
um it's it will become a multi-headed
creature because you might move a level
that has many elements in it to the head
that's really wild okay
so this seems like a good thing all
right contraction
yes so in contraction
we have various functions to do
constructions so
first the general idea of contraction is
having repeated indices inside the table
and and then we have this g applied from
outside which is usually plus
or list but
trace can do all these things right so
the only limitation in trace
which i find annoying is that it always
traces
the top levels
you cannot trace intermediate levels
i understand it's tracing some number of
levels down
but if you have a tensor where you want
to
contract over what is the relationship
between array reduce and contract
uh do you have an example further
and what's tensor contract how does it
relate to this
tensor contracts can do the contractions
and multiples in any in any order but
it's always with plus
it tensor contract is the linear algebra
version of this so always plus
it cannot do any other g and why can't
it be generalized
well we don't want it to be generalized
right it's a math operation
right it's it's a bit like saying we are
going to
generalize debt to do other things
doesn't feel correct
generalize what that
okay okay so that's why there is a
separate array contract that they placed
in the world from function report to do
this okay
but if if if simply trace this
argument that is currently an integer
could be a list of
levels i think it will be great
so wait a minute if if if that argument
two which right now means one comma two
could be an arbitrary list of levels
then you would have the same operation
exactly
although arguably it's kind of more like
a map or reply operation
that should have its function first
well it's it's an afterthought in a
sense it's like we do this in many
places like inner
or distribute etc in which we put the
functions at the end
well the default function is what is
plus is plus
okay so you're saying we don't need a
ray contract if we generalize
tr to have
right there is one one single detail
which is this a detail that will appear
multiple times and it appears in array
reviews
that's something i wanted to to raise
which is that when
when you have these various operations
acting on some levels but not all of
them
there is always the question of what to
do with the other levels
and there is always the two main choices
we put them at the beginning or we put
them
at the end
and various functions do different
things it's also very similar to the
choice of threading at which level
uh sorry threading yeah yeah right from
the end
okay hold on that's uh
i think you should try to open this
notebook uh early operation
[Music]
reviews because that's uh i was kind of
summarizing the idea we had in the
previous meeting
and the difference between a reduce and
level apply like you were really into
level apply
and i actually argue it's less useful
it's more intuitive to do the map column
and that's exactly what jose just said
so
array reduce is actually putting all the
other levels
uh at the end i think no
at the beginning at the beginning
exactly exactly exactly
and uh and level play put all the
all the other level at the end right
is it equivalent to array reduce
otherwise
i i think the best way to understand
array reduce is to compare it to flatten
and there is a section a subsection
further than comparing both
i think that's the easier way a comment
this section
on a comment so
so let's take this array if i evaluate
that array
which one the next one this one
so we take that we take that array which
is an array of d4 with levels
two with that with dimensions two three
four five
now if you do this flatten array of of
two three we are flattening levels two
and three together
so dimensions three and four now become
a dimension twelve
but you see what we do with the other
two levels the two and five we put them
at the end
yes okay so what uh atn is saying is
that the array reduce
in the same scenario puts the two and
five at the beginning
and so this choice of what do we do with
the other levels
appears in many of these operations when
you can act
on arbitrary levels
and an array contract has that very same
problem too
how should i think about this i mean
okay let's talk physics and tensors and
things is there any analog of this there
i mean usually in tensors you're doing
operations
in situ with you know you might you know
do a summation convention over indices
three and six
or something but then all the other
indices stay in place don't they
what where does that where does the
result from three and six being
einstein's sum so to speak go
well well that's turned into a scalar in
those cases
the those levels disappear
oh right the point of tensor contract is
that it
necessarily reduces the rank by two
whereas flatten has this ability
to not i mean it can make levels
disappear
but it can make them disappear sort of
right you know not in the it's not an
all or nothing
sum right okay how should i think about
this where do you put the
remaining levels either in terms of
linear algebra or in terms of
anything else or in terms of depth first
search or whatever what what how should
i think about this
so flatten as i was saying flatten
the the thing with flatten is that it
takes several levels and produces a new
level
rather than zero levels so now the
question is
where to put the other ones with respect
to this one you know
it produces one new level one new level
array reduce
produces how many new levels array
reduce takes n levels in
and produces how many levels out that
depends on the function you put at the
in the first argument that's yeah
in general for like a function like
total
it will go from n level to n minus the
number of levels specified in array
reduce
okay but so then then there's a block of
levels that were produced by the
function in array reduce where do they
get put
do they get put in situ relative to the
other levels or do they get put
beginning or end at the end so the level
that you perform
operation on always have to be at the
end in all of this function i believe
so if you check the notebook on the
right you see even map
what what is map really so if you go
down you see map
map at level three what it does is that
the first
three levels are untouched yeah right
and everything else
is processed and so in the general case
you have
only three level left i mean you could
have more if your function f is not
producing a scalar map thread what it
does
is that it takes you know right you're
making an assumption there
that oh sorry you're doing it precisely
at level three
exactly exactly at level three in that
case uh map thread what it does if you
say map thread level two
it takes the first level always
move it at uh you know of like two two
further
and then apply everything that starts
from this level
to produce something but always applying
at the end
uh level apply that you proposed some
time ago
uh because it's intuitive map colon
that's really i think it's its main
quality
the rest not so much uh level apply
level two you take level two
uh what is that you put it at the top
and you apply f on everything else
that's why it's not that useful is that
you you specify i mean it's a bit like
map where you
specify what to keep and not what to
apply on
uh and typically yeah
and then a reduce where it moves the
level at the
end and apply on this level
something i think it's important here is
to realize that array reduce is a
combination of two operations the first
one is always a flattened or transpose
and the second one is a map
and they are independent
sorry say that again josiah yes so
that's the way i understand nowadays
reduce which is the combination of two
operations consecutively
first always either transpose or flatten
and the second is a map i see
right and the kind of funny thing is
that the actual reduction part in the
name
is a property of the function
right because if you if you have right
if a function returned something of the
same shape as what went in
it wouldn't reduce at all like identity
that's not completely stupid that array
release of identity doesn't do anything
maybe it shouldn't be called reduce then
if it's not guaranteed to reduce
no i don't agree array reduce of
identity the fact that that does nothing
seems just fine to me
yeah but there are other functions which
which are not identical
in principle in principle i think in
practice
basically never happened uh
yeah we should by the way give that
example of a reduce of identity in the
in the properties and relations section
yes i have i've added plenty of examples
there but
it's not true that already reduce of
identity does nothing it does it is
equivalent to flattening it can still
flatten out
i see because it's it's a combination of
both
okay so what what are we all right
so i just wanted to raise this
general topic of what to do with the
other
levels yeah
and what is is there any
intuitive way to understand
you know one is moving i i'm still very
confused i mean you're moving
you're basically saying do the
operations at the top and then some of
the elements
in those operations will have trailing
pieces that are lower
otherwise if you're doing the operations
and you don't know what's coming out
there's no way that can be anything
other than at the bottom can it
exactly it has to be the level at the
bottom that you perform operation on
always
not no no not really think of what trace
us
so trace is put is doing the operations
at the top
and leaving anything behind
inside right that means that it's
leaving as
lumps you know as a as a single lump of
stuff
the trailing sub tensor
right right exactly it doesn't care that
so it for example when you have an array
of depth four
four you could treat that as a matrix of
matrix
and perform matrix operations on the
first two levels yeah right caring
about the fact that the elements are
matrices themselves
and why can't you do that at any level
why can't you go you know why can't you
have a list
of of uh matrices of matrices and then
do that operation
on levels two through uh
two and three exactly you can perfectly
you can
okay we're basically what we're saying
is
treat things below this it's like outer
has this rather crazy you know
number that it gives us its you know
last argument
that says treat it as atomic
below this level exactly yes so for
example here in array reviews
in which we perform operations on two
three it could have decided to leave
one at the beginning and four at the end
that's another possibility
treat as atomic
trailing levels
right that's the main issue how many
trailing levels do you treat as atomic
or do you expect as atomic trailing
levels
or uh put your result
at the at the end of the level list
so this is what we do with with this
integer at the end of out
in outer we say everything beyond level
three
is atomic right
and so everything is left inside so so
these other operations like array reduce
maybe i'm confused but is there a sense
in which
there is also a question of what gets
left atomic at the end
so in other words this is this is the
um there's a notion here
of kind of um you know
okay so there's the the application
levels
the atomic levels
and what what and so application levels
means what you operate on
and the atomic levels means the trailing
thing you leave
and then what else is there then there's
also
the application levels okay application
levels is what you take in
right
so those would be the third argument in
array reviews or the
second argument in flat end etc okay the
atomic levels
what you leave as lumps
uh in the what you leave as innermost
lumps
rick okay so eg
outer has such an atomic levels idea
what else has an atomic levels idea
you're saying trace does
or not no the array contract function
above does but as far as i know in in
the world from language
system functions only outer right now
okay but but the point is that this
this question appears and what we do in
all cases is just to have a default
flatten puts everything at the bottom
right so this is this is a notion
of i mean i don't think this term atomic
levels is absolutely terrible
maybe there's a or or um what's a better
term for it
um
what's that rupee levels say that again
groupie that's in like groupies people
who are just sort of hanging around
i know what groupies i mean i haven't
heard that word used in a long time i
think it's gone out of fashion but um
um it's a along with groovy groupie and
groovy groupies perhaps okay in any case
why is that relevant right because
they're just right there they're not
involved
in in the action
that's right that's a stretch i mean i
think
but rather what i'm thinking of them as
their irreducible lump
i i personally call them effective
depths
or effective ranks
well i mean did that sort of but
i thought we were talking about the
levels we're not touching
right which aren't necessarily linearly
ordered
in the right the effective depth is
you know the depth of the levels we're
actually
manipulating whereas i thought we were
trying to name
all the levels that we're not
manipulating
but the point is that when you have
levels
to have application levels up to four
then
up to four you have to to handle them
and then the question is what to do next
yeah notice all this stuff so these
so this is um so this
in case this is an idea that there is an
end sum
function and this is just a trivial way
of implementing
what they do here and it's another way
of doing summations
traces sums etc
i wanted to show um this is i think a
longer discussion
yes yes we spend much time on the other
one but but
this is simpler this way of of handling
um i mean is it literally the einstein
summation convention
it's a generalization if you open
comments so the
this enzyme functions generalizes in two
ways
i see they can repeat more than once
more than twice
exactly with which we can do with trace
but trace will insist they have to be
the top ones that's why i want to
generalize to any
and then the other thing which trace
already does too
is that it can take functions other than
plus
sure and and the their a einstein
function only takes two possibilities
it's either list or plus okay
fine or whatever but but the nice thing
is that they
they can do that with indices
you mean say which index is to be is to
be
reduced in this way right so the
standard way of of doing
contractions etc in linear algebra is
just to repeat indices now there is this
notation of having
indices go to another list of indices
and the convention is
if the index appears on the left oh
sorry on the right
of the rule then you are using list
if it doesn't appear you are using plus
well whatever i mean
okay look we let these meetings about
list operations kind of
go to seed here a bit over the last few
months i think we need to
you know so we have identified a few
things
that are already implementable or at
least yes i think so
um comments that this conversation was
poorly motivated
and the question is what do neural net
developers find annoying so we have some
neural net developers here so maybe you
can comment on that
matteo i mean i mean for sure this
manipulation of array is super
that's actually what motivated it i'm
aware so
so the question is what is the specific
thing that you need
that we don't yet have
oh broadcasting
which is what we talked about which is
what we're calling threaded
and what we talked about at the
beginning here
yes and uh yeah
i mean we already have this in the
framework but it's to be able to express
it
i know i know that's the primary thing
that was the number one thing that i was
trying to get us to focus on
was how to do that right
and i think we have a concept now and we
just need to work it through
okay is there anything else you want to
bring up there
i think uh yeah i mean these will reduce
um that's typical operations that are
done in neural networks
okay the transpose i think will be
useful as well with with arrow
um i think i don't know jerome i think
there's something else
no okay nick is commenting that he had
an
auto contractable array object once
where
negative dimensions correspond to
contravariant indices isn't that how how
things like how does exact do
controversies indices jose
yes also with a minus in front i mean
a plus or no sign is covariant minus is
sorry the other one plus is contravarian
minus is covalent but the notion of
covariance versus contravariance
is a creature of tensor analysis that
doesn't seem to be
i mean doesn't have a more general role
does it i mean
the fact that you're you know
introducing metric tensors to raise and
lower things
seems like a a detail of operating
you know with tensor analysis on
manifolds and things that does not have
a generalization is that a true
statement
it's linear algebra in linear algebra
you have functions and co functions or
vectors and convectors and you need the
separation
it's like positive and negative it's
just two possibilities
but the general calculus of indices
allows for more possibilities
bigger and linear algebra
wait a minute just just explain
mathematically for a second why
what is it about quotes linear you're
emphasizing the word linear
yes why does that lead to just these two
cases
because the origin of these is having
linear operators and they're having
their
their dual so there is a duality there's
a fundamental duality in linear algebra
that leads to covariance and
contravariant
and and that that's not the case in
general
index computations
explain just for my mathematical moment
here explain
the the way to understand that duality
well i mean contravariant indices are
indices
in in the dual space right space of
linear functionals
right and right if you just have random
arrays of numbers but you don't have
an operator space structure
then there's you know there's no such
thing as a
as a contra variant index yeah
actually it's kind of cool in our in our
hyper graph thing that's kind of below
indices
what this will correspond to is nodes
versus edges
okay yeah it's one of these dualities
with with order two
the dual of the dual is the original
thing so
that's the whole right that's quite
interesting i hadn't really internalized
that before that that's exactly how
because in our setup you know
these spatial coordinates are
effectively um
you know determined by positions of
nodes and then they're these
uh you know little pieces of gd6 that
are
represent the tangent space and anyway
okay so that's how this works
um and by the way i mean the the you
know
for what it's worth and we should wrap
this meeting but but um uh
you know one of the big realizations of
recent times has been
that these hyper graphs are essentially
below tensors they are
if you if you make a bunch of
equivalence classes of
gd6 you kind of assemble a
or or actually of nodes you assemble a
tensor index
but the things you have for individual
ones are sort of below the
below the level of an actual tensor
index
what it's worth um probably probably
more understanding of that can be had in
due course but um
right um let me just also observe that
in the complex case right you actually
have three other spaces
because you also have the conjugated
vector space
and the dual conjugated vector space
which is how you end up
with dotted and undotted indices
i haven't done enough complex tensor
stuff
okay then all right i think we're
supposed to wrap this meeting i believe
we have another meeting which will
involve some of the same people
um coming up in just a couple of minutes
here
um okay i will see you guys uh
um oh actually nick is saying think of
coherent indices as output and
contravariant is the input
for process yeah well or the other way
around
um sounds good okay
see you some of you